ouais on voit bien la trace de monter la
trace de descente de la torture cette
nuit une tortue imbriquée a traîné sur
cette plage ça lourd de carapace
jusqu'à cette lisière de montgrand peut
répondre ses yeux eux sont membres du
réseau tortues marines leur mission
protéger les deux favoris de pompe
c'est une belle femelle à un briquet qui
est venu prendre sept points sur cette
plage c'est assez fréquent qu'elle
vienne compte c'est parce que l'habitat
est assez propice pour les pontes le
sable et meubles il ya de la végétation
en arrière plage donc les imbriquer vont
favoriser en fait de pondre sous la
végétation en lisière de végétation la
période de ponte a commencé au mois de
mars
elle devrait durer jusqu'à octobre 6 -
sous haute surveillance car la
martinique compte trois espèces de
tortues marines
la tortue imbriquée la tortue verte et
la torture sont des espèces menacées
la tortue luth donc atlantique nord
nord-est a été classé en danger
d'extinction des espèces en voie
d'extinction
d'où la nécessité de protéger les nids
puis ces petites tortues
elles sont extrêmement fragiles sur 1000
naissances seule une seule arrivera à
maturité sexuelle et pourra à son tour
se reproduire mais avant elle devra
éviter les prédateurs crabe mangouste et
les oiseaux pour autant il ne faut pas
les surprotéger les petits
donc sortent du nid surtout ne les
touchez pas parce qu'en fait ils ont
besoin de du parcours du nid jusqu'à
jusqu'à la mer pour faire leur pour
construire leurs muscles en fait et ça
leur permet de pouvoir avoir ce repéré
après de pouvoir revenir sur la même
plage généralement c'est qu'ils
survivront partiront vivre dans les eaux
d'amérique centrale
une fois qu'elles atteindront l'âge de
maturité sexuelle leur instinct les
poussera à faire des milliers de
kilomètres pour venir pondre ici sur la
plage de leur naissance